when you came into this world there  gradually arose into being the sensation  of I and you feel that you are I just as  much as I feel that I am i but all the  time everywhere there are other eyes  starting up whether they be human animal  anything you like to be in other  galaxies etc always they are starting up  and so the feeling that we call AI is  how everything feels on the inside  [Music]  you can get a certain vision of life  where everything is seen to be a complex  pattern of rhythm dances  the human dance flower dolls the bee  dance  the giraffe dance and that's what this  all is it's jazz this is a big jazz this  world and what it's trying to do is to  see how jazzed up it can get how far out  this play of rhythm and go  [Music]